the flash mob is kind of interesting
it's been around for a long time it's
been around for a long time it's a
little fun it is fun yeah I get the
appeal of it like by the way I'm a human
being I understand it's fun going let's
run in let's grab some and let's
leave and this is the D.A of La when
he's asked about these things what do
you say to the person who points a
finger at you well I would ask you the
question what would you tell him when
you just heard me speaking right now
because I think you have a
responsibility also for addressing it
why is this guy not Miami yeah sitting
on a cabana yeah I mean he's perfect
he's like what are you talking about we
got that brother here you have to visit
yourself I mean we are here bunny
America you know what's coming here
you're coming here they get the hat back
everybody have to be responsible for
what they doing we see the people we're
going to make them responsible hahaha